el mekong cerca de 70 millones de
personas dependen de él para pescar o
cultivar arroz pero este río legendario
está amenazado por la actividad
industrial
[Música]
en camboya cada día se tragan millones
de toneladas cúbicas de arena
una práctica que tiene un impacto
ecológico masivo por la constante
excavación no se han derrumbado algunas
riberas
este local vive en una de ellas
es uno de los pocos en atreverse a
denunciar el daño que provoca el dragado
aunque lo hace de manera anónima
no estoy contento cuando veo toda esa
extracción porque se destruyen los
recursos naturales el terreno que yo
tenía iba desde aquí hasta el barco
una docena de eco activistas que usaron
criticar públicamente esta práctica
fueron encarcelados
tragar el mekong es una actividad muy
lucrativa porque la arena tiene muchos
usos comerciales sobre todo en el sector
de la construcción
la capital phom penh está en pleno
desarrollo inmobiliario
la arena del mekong es usada para crear
estas franjas de tierra artificiales que
han empezado a invadir el río sobre
estas islas artificiales a orillas del
cauce se construirán rascacielos
los informes del gobierno que señalaban
el impacto de este nuevo complejo sobre
el ecosistema del río nunca se hicieron
públicos
nuestros colegas de france 2 les
pidieron más información a los
promotores del proyecto y a las
autoridades pero no recibieron respuesta
[Música]
las comunidades locales ahora se
enfrentan al de salud
claro que
sí
este director de una ong local ayuda a
los habitantes de la zona a luchar por
salvar sus casas
vivimos aquí en un área rural antes que
estábamos seguir llevado más vegetales
pero perdimos ese modo de vida porque
las grandes empresas han ocupado los
lagos
esta comunidad podría quedar borrada del
mapa porque los lagos que rodean la
capital también son rellenados de arena
para crear grandes complejos urbanos
esta franja de tierra vacía solía ser un
lago
para jean botti todos tendrán que pagar
el costo ecológico pero sólo unos pocos
se beneficiarán por el desarrollo
tenemos una pregunta importante para el
biliar para quien sólo esas viviendas
porque muchas personas pobres no pueden
pagarlas y muchas han sido expulsadas o
desplazados de la ciudad
entonces esto es realmente para las
personas o es para los ricos los
inversionistas
invest a
las presas hidroeléctricas también
amenazan el futuro del mejor
estas inmensas estructuras se están
construyendo en laos y china
[Música]
aunque son una fuente de energía baja en
emisiones de carbono impiden que los
pescadores locales vivan del río
en camboya este local pescó en las
generosas aguas del mekong durante más
de 40 años pero al igual que los demás
pescadores tuvo que abandonar su negocio
ahora recolectan conchas
a medida que los países que rodean el
mekong se siguen industrializando la
presión sobre el ecosistema del río no
hará más que aumentar durante los
próximos años
[Música]